[Musica]
buonasera
[Applauso]
allora quasi racconta del viaggio
il viaggio è un percorso fatto di tappe
tappe che ti fanno crescere tappe che ti
trasformano tappe che ti modellano è
questa questo è il racconto della mia
ragione del mio ultima porzione di
viaggio ok
tra pochi mesi compirà 40 anni lo so
sembra più giovane lo dico per voi in
realtà l'aveva presa bene come notizia
non ci stavo male a pensarmi un pochino
più vicino a mezzo secolo
ok il metabolismo nei più lo stesso se
mangio una peperonata mi si ripropone
proprio puntuale come la chiamata di un
call center ma per il resto non sentivo
una grande pressione
fino a che mi sono improvvisamente
irrimediabilmente trovata single
sono stata sposata quasi cinque anni con
tutto ciò che ne consegue
l'innesto di un nuova famiglia di nuovi
amici viaggi di gruppo eccetera eccetera
eccetera cinque anni felici
poi il mio matrimonio finito
allora spiegarvi il motivo sarebbe
complesso perché io francesco come la
maggior parte delle coppie che si
separano
abbiamo due versioni diverse
dell'accaduto comunque all'improvviso mi
sono ritrovata single anche felicemente
single da qualche mese ma non potevo
dirlo in giro perché felicemente single
per molti sono due parole che non
possono stare nella stessa frase per la
vostra società essere una donna sola di
quasi 40 anni che non sente il bisogno
di essere legittimata attraverso una
famiglia è un disastro
allora non vi dico quando ho avvisato i
miei una delle preoccupazioni più
frequenti era e adesso quando lo trovi
un altro
perché non importa se sei una
tendenzialmente risolta in psicoterapia
da anni 9 anni belli
il mio dottore si è fatto casanuova coi
miei problemi e ma non importa
quando stai per compiere quarant'anni
giochi un'altra partita quella delle
ultime cartucce da sparare quella che se
sei sposata ok ma se sei single
bella è tardi per trovare una mostrano
uno giusto
come se non fosse pensabile essere
felici anche da sole anche vivendo i
sentimenti quando capitano senza
cercarli sono stata male per la fine del
mio matrimonio
dopo la prima fase faticosa perché
separarsi qualunque cosa vi dicano e
faticoso
mi sono ritrovata per ora a
riorganizzare mia vita non più cena col
marito ma per itv aperitivo con le
amiche ok io amo le mie amiche loro la
lunga un po meno però dopo aver svoltato
un sacco di cene pagate da loro perché
sai tu andreas è già come stai poveri
noi paghiamo noi ho capito che dovevo
cominciare a guardarmi in giro
ma cosa si frequenta 40 anni in un mondo
dove non sei più una coppia doveva la
gente della mia età per conoscere altre
persone
escluso padre e supermercati dei single
che abbiamo capito tutti che sono una
boiata pazzesca ok
beh si va sui social ma come ho fatto a
non pensarci subito proprio io
i social sono un mondo a me conosciuto
sono una seconda casa per me in quel
momento sono diventati anche al mio
rifugio o la mia zona di caccia se
preferite
ho iniziato a sperimentare questo
percorso molto breve che dai cuoricini
sotto le foto di instagram porta ai
commenti pubblici poi ai messaggi
privati con tante moti contiene di cuori
poi alle foto sexy però che si auto di
auto distributo dopo una sola visione ok
così mi hanno detto cioè ecco dovrebbe
si autodistruggono vero
si vabbè dopo ci penso dopo le foto ci
sono i messaggi vocali e poi dopo
dovrebbe arrivare l'incontro ma
attenzione in un anno non ho mai chiuso
questo cerchio ci credete cioè non che
io fossi respira e che mi hanno dato
tutti buca per i motivi più strani una
risposta su tutta è stata non sono un
uomo oggetto ve lo giuro oppure non ti
chiedo di salire perché voglio costruire
qualcosa di serio andrea oppure hai dei
capelli bellissimi come quelle di mia
madre da giovane
oppure infine vorrà per chiudere casa e
tua di proprietà tube dei figli perché
io li voglio
lì sono scappata io
però questo racconto in un'altra
occasione comunque ad un certo punto la
notizia della mia singletudine è
diventata di dominio pubblico la
classica paparazzata allora aperta
parentesi
allora le mie paparazzate sono tutte è
tristemente poco eleganti in una uscivo
da una salumeria in un'altra sembrava
avessi fatto a botte con la mia
estetista e che nelle mie proiezioni da
bambina nei miei sogni c'era sempre
paparazzata da diva fuori da una
gioielleria uno yacht
oppure sulla spiaggia correndo coi
capelli al vento anche soffrendo ma
bellissima e invece la realtà è la
salumeria
comunque chiusa parentesi
la conferma della mia separazione
comunque un po di curiosità nei luoghi
che frequentavo l'ha creata la gente per
prima secca cioè se proprio creata una
domanda fondamentale
vi siete traditi non me lo chiedevano
proprio mi fermavano prestata per
chiedermelo alle mie risposte di mancata
guerra civile alle mie rassicurazioni
cominciavano ad osservarmi con una sorta
di compassionevole pena misto a
tenerezza mielosa
alle soglie dei 40 ero diventata una
povera vittima
alla fine di una storia
però saltavo le file ricevevo regali mi
offrivano millemila caffè
mi hanno anche proposto un cane per non
sentirmi sola ma io ho capito già
e non farò battute in merito però
all'inizio mi ha fatto anche piacere
tutto questo ma poi ho capito che mi
stavano trattando come una bambina
commesse in quanto donna sola dove dovrà
necessariamente essere accudita difesa
non è che non mi faccia piacere che gli
amici si prendono cura di me ma quando è
la società a farlo mi viene il dubbio
che dipenda ancora una volta da come
siamo considerati noi donne e la cosa mi
fa pensare
solo donna ma non mi sento il sesso
debole sono donna e mi piacerebbe che il
rispetto non passasse da commemorazioni
in cui in un solo giorno dell'anno si
ricordino quante donne sono state
aggredite e uccise dai loro compagni
un giorno solo
ne basta uno no c'è molto di più sono
donna e se faccio una foto sexy o se
vado vestita in giro come mi pare vorrei
che la cosa non mettesse in discussione
questo non essere pensante
non ho bisogno di mostrarmi lo so e non
sapete quante volte ho sentito questa
frase ma se mi sveglio la mattina e
deciso di farlo non voglio sentirmi dire
che perde di credibilità perché il mio
corpo toglie importanza a quello che
dico penso e scrivo sono donna e sono
libera e pretendo che la mia libertà sia
rispettata
rispettata come essere umano non come
essere fragile da proteggere io non
voglio essere protetta io voglio essere
rispettata e il rispetto si costruisce
giorno per giorno dalle cose più piccole
da sempre
sto per compiere 40 anni sono single e
forse non mi risposerò forse non avrò
figlio forse sì non lo so ma voglio dire
che la vita di una donna non finisce qui
a prescindere che tu abbia una famiglia
tradizionale o no è che le mie
prospettive non si possono misurare su
mariti fidanzati o amanti
dobbiamo smettere di considerare la
donna adulta bisognosa di altro per
essere completa di uomini di fili o di
aiuto
noi donne abbiamo solo bisogno dei
nostri diritti che si rispettino i
nostri diritti nel lavoro in famiglia
nel mondo non della compassione di
nessuno
non vogliamo favore da nessuno siamo
tutte vittime delle aspettative degli
altri ma quelli che gli altri pensano
sia giusto normale per noi non deve mai
vedere come regola c'è chi ha
ottant'anni prende una laurea che a 60
decide di parlare in discoteca con
tacchi a spillo minigonna che a 50 di
stream mare su tweet chi fa balletti su
tik tok chi lascia tutto è parte
e che a 39 anni decide di divorziare
o di frequentare un ragazzo
sensibilmente più giovane
ho letto anche questo sì che però ti
porta una ventata di leggerezza che non
ti chiede di andare a convivere dopo una
settimana o se vuoi un figlio subito o
se stare insieme per sempre ma vuole
conoscerti stare bene con te
e questo parlano di me
mi chiamo andrea o quasi 40 anni e sono
una donna felice
[Applauso]